avec nous pour en parler ce soir
l'économiste thomas poder qui est
professeur à l'école de santé publique
de l'université de montréal bonsoir
bonsoir
comment expliquer cet écart quand même
exceptionnel un tri sera elle et les
autres pays
donc effectivement il un écart qui est
très important à la fois en termes de
doses reçues mais aussi en termes de
doses administrées
le chef graphique vous allez présenter
c'était pour les les doses administrées
il faut savoir que israël se prépare
depuis a très longtemps en fait depuis
moins de joie déjà ils ont signé un
accord de préachat avec la compagnie
moderna ensuite c'est un pays qui comme
vous le savez il ya des conflits depuis
la création et depuis 1948 donc les
systèmes de les systèmes de
fonctionnement de l'état sont
habituelles à travailler d'une façon
très organisée
quasi militaire donc ça aide aussi
beaucoup en terme de logistique pour ce
qui est un provisionnement et
administration d edf
c'est aussi un pays qui a mis en place
des mesures spécifiques pour la
vaccination de son système de santé
actuellement pour la vaccination
fonctionne 24 heures sur 24 7 heures 7
jours sur 7
ils ont mis en place beaucoup de
cliniques de vaccination au québec en
entre 20 et 30 pour une population qui
est de taille comparable en israël ils
ont plus de 150 cliniques de vaccination
ils ont mis aussi en place des
camionnettes de vaccination pour aller
dans les endroits un peu plus reculées
bon c'est certain que la densité de
population est plus importante en israël
qu au québec ça doit aider aussi vous
avez tout un ensemble d'événements
d'éléments plutôt qu'ils font en sorte
que pour israël cela fonctionne donc
c'est une question d'organisation
clairement c'est principalement une
question d'organisation
vous avez un système de santé qui est
très très numérique à partir de 18 ans
vous êtes obligé de vous inscrire à
beaucoup système santé mais dracénois
santé qui est numérique c'est à dire que
vous êtes suivi vous avez des courriels
vous avez accès à votre dossier en ligne
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour aller
chercher la population pour lui donner
surtout de l'information où sont les
cliniques qu'il reçoive sa par courriel
est-ce que c'est leur tour d'aller être
vaccinés ils reçoivent également sa par
courriel donc c'est évident que ça
fascinant dans ces circonstances on est
loin du fac cela dont on évoque un peu
encore toujours l'existence dans notre
système chez nous est ce qu'il ya des
incitatifs financiers qui sont peut-être
plus important en israël pour avoir
davantage personnel pour tous et pour
tous ses centres de vaccination ils ça
dépend toujours où est ce qu'on met la
priorité est certain qu'ils ont libéré
du personnel pour aller dans les centres
de vaccination et effectuer la
vaccination
ils ont aussi mobilisé l'armée l'armée
est en suppléant de façon très
importante dans la stratégie de
vaccination en israël non c'est
évidemment le personnel médical de
l'armée mais c'est également les andelys
ambulanciers réservistes donc on peut
être pas salles au québec évidence qu'on
est pas une situation de deux guerres
intestines ou ou larvée ce qui fait que
eux ils ont beaucoup d'ambulanciers en
réserve qu'ils ont pu qu'ils ont pu
utiliser pour la vaccination
donc je vous écoute j'ai l'impression
d'entendre de votre part une description
d'un système très efficace pour faire
fonctionner cette vaccination par
rapport à un système chez nous qui sont
davantage sclérosé et finalement très
complexe un système qui à un certain
nombre de lourdeur au québec
un système qui n'est pas très prévoyants
non plus au début une intervention je
disais qu'il se fait plusieurs mois
qu'ils préparent soit depuis le mois de
juin au québec on a l'impression que ce
fait peu de temps finalement qui prépare
ça alors que c'était quand même
prévisible
par exemple moi j'ai travaillé dans un
hôpital pendant un certain nombre
d'années puis je fais partie centre de
recherche on a reçu au cours du mois de
décembre
un courriel de la direction du centre de
recherche nous disant que le
gouvernement québécois chercher des des
frites des réfrigérateurs donc à très
basse température pour conserver les
vaccins qui leur étaient livrées
donc on aurait pu se poser la question
de savoir est ce qu'on a les
réfrigérateurs bien avant le milieu du
mois de décembre je trouvais ça vraiment
très surprenant mais en même temps très
révélateur du de l'impréparation
finalement à
que le système a par rapport à cette
stratégie de vaccination est ce
qu'israël a payé plus cher et a conclu
de meilleurs contrats des plus gros
contrats plus rapidement mais à payer
plus cher pour ses contrats
d'approvisionnement en vaccins voulu
dire en israël oui oui en fait on n'aura
jamais le vrai chiffre de toute façon
parce que ces ententes confidentielles
c'est la même chose au québec on n'a pas
le prix des médicaments avait l on a des
prix faciaux et ensuite et des
ristournes qui sont appliquées donc les
ristournes varie entre 5 et 15%
voilà on est dans un cas de figure
particulier donc une situation d'urgence
au niveau mondial donc sans doute qu'il
n'y a pas eu de ristournes j'ai même
entendu
alors est-ce que les sources sont
crédibles ou pas en tout cas ça venait
de médias israéliens qui disait que le
gouvernement israélien avait payé plus
cher que le prix annoncé
les doses de vaccins qu'ils auraient
acquis on compare les d'un surcoût de 30
40 % est ce que c'est réel je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas s'ils sont des
chiffres qui courent il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises un bio technologie en
israël
est ce que ça change quelque chose selon
vous je pense que ça change quelque
chose au niveau des contacts qui sont
établis avec les compagnies
pharmaceutiques
quand vous êtes impayés avec beaucoup
d'industries pharmaceutiques de
biotechnologie vous êtes évidemment en
contact régulier avec les acteurs
majeurs que sont fait peur en moderna et
c'est donc ce qui commercialise
actuellement le vaccin et a
partiellement là vous avez des contacts
plus facile entre les industries mais
aussi entre le gouvernement et les
industries puis ça parle aussi d'une
volonté politique forte
benjamin netanyahu qui est donc
effectivement le premier ministre là bas
il ya des élections bientôt au mois de
mars puis c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît
aussi pour son dynamisme il n'a pas
hésité a directement contacté les
dirigeants de ces compagnies
pharmaceutiques
évidemment il a dû avoir accès à des
réseaux de contacts de son milieu
économique local
dernier point en terminant est-ce que
vous pensez que chez nous au canada au
québec en ontario
il faut revoir notre plan de déploiement
de factice nation là il ya deux choses
dans le plan de déploiement ça veut dire
la priorisation use
dire la façon dont un ministre compte
comme dans on organise en fait la
vaccination
en ce qui concerne la priorisation ça
semble être à peu près la même chose
dans tous les pays du monde
en israël c'est la même en terme de
personne à prioriser pour la vaccination
c'est à dire les personnes très
vulnérables en premier et ensuite le
réseau de la santé donc les travailleurs
de santé qui sont en contact avec des
gens qui ont la cog hill je sais qu'il
est une petite polémique en ce moment
mais le problème est en tout cas en
israël rapidement réglé dans la mesure
où le personnel de santé et les
personnes les plus vulnérables ont déjà
été vaccinées donc c'est surtout au
niveau logistique
donc au niveau logistique au québec il y
aurait sans doute intérêt à avoir
davantage de communication / ou est ce
qu'on peut se relaxer mais voilà à avoir
davantage de sites de vaccination
et puis avoir du personnel pour faire
sanctionner effectivement ces sites de
vaccination donc pourquoi pas faire
appel à l'armée comme ça a été le cas en
israël de toute façon au cas là c'est
déjà plus ou moins le cas puisque
l'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement
et la distribution aux provinces et déjà
assurée par l'armée canadienne
mais c'est pas grave on s'arrête si vous
êtes passionnant merci beaucoup pour ses
explications ce soit très clair vous en
prie merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit